yahia on m'a dit on m'a dit t'es où on
m'a piqué yaya
on m'a dit t'es où on m'a dit et au bout
on m'a dit eh oui après tout moi j'ai
deux là peuvent via gnagna et je fais la
fine danse à la peuf la gnagna j'arrête
pas de marc tessier se serait gnagna
mais ne pourrait pas la pierre est la
cerdagne à royat je suis dans le club
pris mon petit bt ou coma bouteille de
champagne est plus grosse que ça la
presse jusque quand j'étais aux stars
mais dis-moi été ou seront tu veux mon
06 avait pas le numéro d'écrou
et puis on allemandes italiennes en
anglais la justice monsieur la halle te
demande pas si je pèse s'inquiète pas je
suis déçu comme tv au complet je suis à
l'aise dédicace aux vrais dr jean marc
est obligé de reléguer ni le feu ni fou
ni plonge les ai pu ni puni soir je vais
d qu'unique unie rau comme le fit
surtout moi je suis venu faire un carton
marchera pas sur les baskets 2001 le
pardon bref on m'a dit c'est vous on m'a
dit d où on m'a vite et on m'a dit t'es
ouf on m'a dit t'es où
on m'a dit m
by ap et ont acheté de la peuf la gnagna
ai-je fait l'afrique danse à la peuf
gnagnagna j'arrête pas de mal nécessaire
via gnagna mais pourrait pas la chaîne
cnn
non ma fille joint défoncé ma peu prince
et du sal titres marocains avec ma carte
nationale rejetait pas menti je
m'arrache au bled ça fait mal j'vois pas
qu'ils peuvent stopper à part un clope
et une balle va rentrer et entièrement %
fut jamais à l'heure les gens c'est
comme les pièces ils sont deux faces et
très peu de valeur toujours relever
quand je suis tombé à terre petit je
pars en tournée de sheitan vue avait a
cherché en feat avec un jeune aux
criquets rhymes tu es mort dans le
premier round
salam aleikoum on m'a dit et vous lui
donniez gnagna pour ma part mon poignet
réchauffement planétaire bref on m'a
cité ou qu on m'a dit t'es où
on m'a dit m
on m'a dit tu es ou ont validé au format
vidéo
yang a bien failli à fait ton archet de
la peña el fellah qui donne à la peuvent
venir gnagna j'arrête pas de moi this is
f la gnagna mais je pourrais pas la rai
la cerdagne à gré la cera gna gna
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]